[Music]
j-hope said you are being held out for a
violation of tools here to comment it
ain't easy watching your brother fall
like that but hey this is what we work
for all right look J goes to the most
honest you
I've been here advisor for four years
you really want them to hear you
you gotta be willing to sacrifice is it
choice you chose to sit out I chose a
stand up another point you think you
making son now is not the time you want
the captain on this team you better act
like it don't believe I am coach really
I just want to help on my team eight-man
tournament ass zombie everything is real
if you and I want to try and make it
into the league I can't have anyone else
in there here so you sure this agent
knows what he has in you you're so much
more than basketball
take that down okay whoa what's up
Kimber you ready touch her
yeah I need some know earth man so I'm
your trainer for the next couple months
these next few days he has a chance to
really impress the scouts math handles
all of LeBrons quarter
what you call it I'm not done Z it's
time to put people on notice I want you
to get out there and get us the stuff
those were your decisions do it that's
the anxiety all right use our success
hinges on authenticity boy there we go
looking just like your film really
giving athletes a voice to become more
than happy it took me a while to
understand the opportunity that I was
given
[Applause]
if you want it bad enough if you're
willing to sacrifice it will find you I
have a private fridge stocked with
Kampuchea in my trailer if you'd be
interested no they were good yeah we'll
just catch you later okay
[Music]
you